my father Frank Olson was army scientist
his research group had a relationship
with the CIA they take him to New York
Tuesday morning early Saturday morning
he's dead
what was my father doing what was the
CIA doing o clock and we're back it's
episode 81 man 80 one of them already I
know we're gonna have to like the
hundredth one is coming up yeah so we're
definitely gonna have to and you know
the hundred and fourth episode will
actually be our two-year anniversary no
[ __ ] well I went by fast
yeah it did well this one was a request
this is a show about MKULTRA this has
actually been requested several times
yeah so we're finally getting around to
doing this yeah I remember last week
somebody in the comment says could you
please do them keel yeah it was on the
list we got we got to it about yeah we
finally got around to it we usually will
get around to most people's requests
sometimes it just takes us a really long
time yeah that's all
so before okay before we get to all that
let's do our regular shout outs yeah
just like always faceless villain is out
I'm still working on the second volume
cuz I know a couple of people have asked
me about it you were waiting for me yeah
it's you know it's taking me a very long
time because I have like tons of other
stuff going on too so it's hard for me
to get time to work on it but books
selling well - yeah the first one is is
selling very well yeah so thanks to
everyone who bought it yeah and like
share subscribe yes tell everybody tell
your friends tell everything about the
book also our latest movie review was
demon seed yep
the it was from 1977 right yeah it 1977
sci-fi film it's cool because it seemed
like a lot of people that commented are
like I never heard of this one or the
breathing I'm gonna check it out on our
recommendation there really weren't any
good or well done reviews of that movie
yeah so we kind of filthy
fallen through the cracks which is kind
of a shame because it's kind of a cool
which is weird I hope it gets as big as
our Logan's Run review Logan's Run
review it's got a lot of hits man that's
like think that might be the number one
idea yeah that might be our most watched
one on you yeah definitely and other
than that let's see um I still have a
bunch of shirts available and also a
tote bag on our zazzle store which is a
SOCOM slash 13 o'clock so you're gonna
go check that out also I want to give a
shout out to our newest patron on
patreon whose name is Corinthian oh my
god like fine what car was that again
that was the coordinator Christ that's
right oh my god were so old yeah like
younger people like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about yeah it was a very
famous like old commercial yeah it was
just like a very common cake are dressed
up to be kind of like a luxury card yeah
they want to make it sound fancier
though well yeah so thank you to our
newest patron fine Corinthian leather
and also if you would like to become a
patron obviously you can go to our
patreon which is patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or if you don't like
patreon which I know a lot of people
don't you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account oh I also wanted to
mention this too I probably mentioned it
on here before but I have a horror blog
the cog goddess of hellfire I write
movie reviews on there although I don't
write as much as I would like to just
because like I said because of the world
logo yeah so and stuff like that but a
couple days ago I put up I have a series
on their like horror double feature and
I usually just pick two movies on
Netflix at random and write reviews of
them and we actually watch two horror
comedies on Netflix
welcome to Willits yeah and Ava's
possessions yeah they were good the
first one was from 2017 and the second
was from 2015 and I actually wrote a
review of both of them and the weird
thing was when I posted it on Facebook
and I've never had this happen before
because I've done like a bunch of movie
reviews of newer movies and stuff like
that but I posted on Facebook and the
guy that wrote welcome to
yeah cuz him and his brother um made
that movie yeah I've made the movie like
his brother
Trevor's the director and Tim as the
writer the Ryan brothers and Tim Ryan
actually saw it hmm and commented on
he's like oh thanks for the review and
all this other stuff and shared it
around and friended me and all this
other stuff and then the day after that
the guy who directed Ava's possessions
also some and shared it around in his
page so I was like wow that has never
happened before yeah there were good
movies I mean I really liked welcome to
bullets really stood out I said we got
to do a review on this yeah and then we
mentioned did a little bit later but it
was it was well-written a horror movie
kind of like back in the day it would
have stood out even back in the day and
it was funny without being like without
over-the-top yeah without being like
zany or wacky or anything
I liked the humor and it had good like
old-school practical effects and good
writing and good characters it was just
you know usually a lot of American
movies of the ones that are coming out
now in mainstream Hollywood they suck
but this was a good one man and give you
some hope for independent films well
like I said and Ava's possessions I
really like that too I really liked them
and both of the both of these movies
they kind of took sort of like a worn
out horror cliche premise and did just
like really original stuff with it I
really liked that but I do feel like and
I probably have mentioned this before
but you know since I'm a horror movie
person and that's mostly what I see
independent horror I really think is
going through kind of a renaissance yeah
the last few years I mean most of the
movies even most of the ones that that
I've watched on Netflix in the past say
you know three four or five years yet
most of them have been excellent we may
be on the verge of getting a new
Cronenberg who knows wouldn't that be
something we were actually I was just
talking about David Cronenberg the other
day because we really need to give
really the only David Cronenberg movie
we've done so far on our movie right
today's video John yeah but I gotta get
the brood yeah we got to do the brood at
least I got to order it and shivers we
also had a recommendation to do rabid
which I would like to do I mean I wrote
about Dead Ringers on my blog like a
while back and I wouldn't mind doing a
review of Dead Ringers as well cuz
that's probably my favorite Cronenberg
movie but you know we'll get around to
maybe maybe we'll have those guys on one
day yeah that would be that would be
some
if they want to come on you know yeah
sure all right so now before we get into
the main topic since this is about
MKULTRA which is about drugs man
yeah I actually for our current event
news stories okay so the MKULTRA stuff
this is like super [ __ ] depressing
like and it's one of those things where
the topic is so huge and it's like you
start reading about one thing and
there's like all these rabbit holes that
you go down so it's like this is
probably gonna be able to pursue rowling
yeah and Kayla had a lot ramshackle kind
of show and she'll try had a lot of
different departments going on a lot of
different right there's a lot of [ __ ]
got over all of the in-depth yeah but
you know well like I said we'll kind of
just talk about stuff that was
interesting so I thought well before we
get into the horribly depressing [ __ ]
about MKULTRA I said I found two little
funny drug related news stories I don't
know I guess they're kind of funny I
thought they were funny the first one
actually took place in Portugal and
there was a guy who was caught in the
airport in Lisbon this was February 12th
and they actually caught him because he
was trying to smuggle cocaine into the
country and the cocaine he was carrying
it in a fake ass like he had a fake ass
on yeah and the pictures there cuz there
are pictures and I'll put them in the
YouTube video yeah I'm just like this
guy's I don't know if these Roos
underwear or even just shorts because it
looked like a kind of a bathing suit
like a tropical kind of thing and he
just had these two little like butt
cheeks yeah yeah like where I got this
news story from yeah it says that and I
love this it says the UH 32 year old
unidentified man was detained at the tax
and customs authority and searched where
his unusual derriere aroused suspicion
the interesting thing and actually I
didn't really know this but in Portugal
I guess drug use and drug possession
isn't is decriminalized okay yeah
however trafficking and smuggling drugs
into the country is still illegal for us
so you know so this guy actually did get
in trouble but I was like you know props
you man for trash trucks in a fake yeah
got greedy I get too much it was two
pounds two paths which it which I
thought it sounded like a lot but when
you see the picture it's like well
that's actually not maybe it wasn't moon
right that's what I'm yeah somebody
musta hit maybe you know their height
they would they did the wise thing and
they hired like some gay security guards
there and he's gone that isn't moving
right moving right right that's the
implication being that the guards would
have to be like checking out people's
asses of course in order to notice that
that Dee's ass looked kind of weirdly
lumpy hey yeah I went through security
coming back from New Orleans I was kind
of suspicious of the guy that was Pat me
down to do this white from right to left
you know what I mean yeah like I'm did
I'm right-handed it's going with the
flow yeah you and you were not smuggling
any drug no gas no not that I know of no
and okay so the this is this other story
I guess is kind of funny but not this
happened on Valentine's Day there's
actually a daycare center and one of the
kids brought in some Valentine's Day
cookies for the teachers and the kids
and stuff like that you know that was
nice one of their parents had made them
except now what like the teachers ate
them and like 15 minutes later they're
like I feel hi I guess somebody brought
the weed cookies like I don't know
they're still as far as I know like the
last thing I read about this like I
don't know I guess it's not funny
because it's a little kid well yeah I
don't know it's harmless yeah I think
it's kind of funny to Charlie but so I
don't know if they actually made two
batches like oh this is the normal batch
for the daycare and this is the weed
batch just for us you know what I mean
it's then they switch again I think I
don't know if that's what happened
probably or if the parents were just
like wouldn't it be funny if probably
I kind of think it was probably you
wouldn't waste that on the kids that
yeah that's right just like if you had
good weed and you're gonna get some weed
cookies like fat all those things no you
just you keep that from self half the
kids wouldn't notice it probably what I
wouldn't notice it yeah they probably
wouldn't yeah it was actually the
teacher said Rose I don't know if any of
the kids actually hate them or not but
they're still like investigating whether
there was anything in there or whether
some teachers just like no but yeah so
that was the other story that was
actually from Valentine's Day now let's
talk about project MKULTRA yeah big
subject kind of a dark chapter in
American history I suppose well at least
at least it's a dark chapter we know
about there's probably a lot of other
stuff that we'll never know about yes
and really the only reason we know about
this is because I mean and there's a lot
of it we don't know because a lot of the
records were destroyed and the only
reason we know as much as we do is
because somebody misfiled some of the
files or put them in the wrong place or
something and they actually were found
later on like in 1975 I believe it was
but most of the records have been
destroyed so really we're just kind of
left to piece together what happened
yeah do you want me to tell them what
this project kind of was yeah all right
well everybody knows about the Manhattan
Project yeah that was about making
nuclear weaponry yeah but there was
another project okay MKULTRA was a part
of this project and that was the project
about chemical and biological weapons
all right so that's really what MKULTRA
was about making non-lethal weapons or
making biological weapons and LSD was
considered to be a non-lethal weapon
they were research in that and then they
were also trying to figure out
biological weapons how to kill the enemy
with certain diseases and the reason why
you might want to do that is because if
you hit somebody with an atomic bomb
everyone knows the United States did it
it's not deniable yeah but if you hit an
enemy with a plague you can
theoretically deny that you did it that
way you would escape retaliation all
right and that's what MKULTRA was a part
of that program yeah and MKULTRA it
should be noted is not really one
thing it was actually at least 150
probably more separate little sub
projects and each of them were working
on different things so yes they were
working on biological weapons
weaponizing diseases things of that
nature
they were also experimenting with
various quote-unquote interrogation
techniques using drugs sensory
deprivation hypnosis that kind of stuff
mind white.they mind wipe mind control
okay order to see if they could some of
the things they were working on they
were trying to see if they could kind of
erase them one's personality it was like
a robot agent well and part of the idea
is is that you could capture an enemy
intelligence operative and extract
information from him using drugs so in
other words you find out his secrets
yeah like a truth serum another thing
that you could do is you can take one of
your own agents and erase a secret from
him so he can't remember the secrets
that he had and so that was a lot of
stuff they were working on one of the
things I think a lot of people associate
with MKULTRA is the search for a
quote-unquote Manchurian Candidate where
you could take someone and essentially
get them to say assassinate another
world leader or do whatever you told
them to do and then make them lose their
memory of it there are things of that
nature now the Manchurian Candidate
angle is kind of controversial being
controversial because some researchers
have said well they weren't really doing
that per se that was just one of the
things they kind of release to the media
because it was such a quote/unquote
ridiculous sounding thing that you know
that people would be less likely to kind
of look into the other kind of lesser
ridiculous things they were doing but so
I don't know it does definitely sound
like that's something they would have
been exploring right because well here's
the thing now MKULTRA - it it didn't
start out as MKULTRA it actually started
out well [ __ ] it started out pretty much
like after World War Two mm-hmm you got
all your Nazi scientists it was a
Nuremberg trial which was 1947 I believe
one of the ironic thanks to me is that
so after the Nuremberg trial and
everybody in the world is obviously
horrified by these
the scientists that we're doing these
experiments on the concentration camp
prisoners and things like that and oh so
horrible and anything like that but
really it was only a couple years later
that the us were like yeah we're gonna
get in on that [ __ ] and their operation
paperclip
yes steal all Nazi information in
technology well and about 15 buy the bad
stuff yeah about 1,500 Nazi scientists
were brought to the US after and put in
various research positions and yeah that
was called Operation Paperclip because
they wanted that knowledge all of this
horrible unethical experimentation they
had yeah you didn't want the data from
that on all those you know unethical
experimentations to go to waste
people died for that yeah they're like
well there's already so might as well
yeah why make their sacrifice in vain
listen at least get the data from that
so it never has to happen again that's
one way to look at it yeah yeah yeah I
guess you're right and like I said I'm
sure that's probably how they approached
it also yeah they were practical yeah
another thing we have okay I was like
the backup and we'll talk a little bit
about the CIA all right MKULTRA and CIA
of course into the CIA program when your
average civilian thinks of the CIA they
think of a spy but you know guys from
military and government backgrounds like
you know I had family you know I'm
ex-military and have family in the State
Department federal government see I am
not really spies we think of him as
spooks
yeah spook lies distorts and obscures
the truth he does this to the American
people and to enemy civilians and enemy
governments that's really what they do a
lot of the times yeah and so MKULTRA and
mind-altering drugs can really possibly
help a spook agency get some of this
done yeah like they use a lot of
distraction ninja skills yeah basically
ya know and a lot of has to do with
manipulating headlines and obscuring
what actually happened that type of deal
which they're still doing they still in
this case they still do it still doing
it about this particular this stuff
about how dare you question the
intelligence community at communities if
you know the truth the intelligence
agencies are there to find out the truth
and then lie about it
yeah and to hide the truth so no never
trust
never Intel trust intelligence agencies
yeah so okay what probably the the root
of MKULTRA other than Operation
Paperclip in the Nazi scientists that
came here and the results of their
research was project artichoke which was
actually that was more soldiers who were
being used to test they sort of had
consent from the soldiers like they knew
they were being experimented on but in a
lot of cases they were not told the
entire truth they were told well you're
gonna be testing gas masks or this
various equipment yeah go on yeah I
remember that I saw them the the films
of this the videos yes kind of funny
right so what happened like I said these
guys you know most this [ __ ] about
MKULTRA that people are horrified by is
that they experiment on people who
didn't know they were being experimented
on although in artichoke soldiers did
know they were being experimented on but
they didn't really know what a what
exactly they were being given they were
told well you're gonna test all these
gas masks you're gonna test this
equipment and stuff like that and then
they would put gas masks on them or this
various equipment on them and then they
would dose them with nerve agents
mustard gas sarin gas all kind of things
like that now the problem here is that
yes they knew they were being
experimented on yes they probably now
some of them did try to sue later I was
like a class-action lawsuit and I think
they were given a payoff but in general
around 1950 there was actually a Supreme
Court case I think it was called Ferris
versus United States or something like
that where they basically said look if
you're in the military and you they
experiment on you or you get hurt
somehow like in the course of the
military operations then you're [ __ ] out
of luck yeah you can't sue you can't do
anything like that so that's kind of
what ended up happening to a lot of them
even though a lot of them had lingering
effects obviously from all of these
gases and stuff they were sprayed with
they were also given LSD and various
drugs and stuff like that and there are
actually if you look on YouTube there's
some documentaries about it and they
have film of these soldiers that have
been given LSD and then they're given
tasks
they're say okay well run this obstacle
course yeah or put this rifle together
and I'm not sure exactly what the dosage
of it wasn't pretty huh it must have
been pretty high there because
especially I felt bad for the one dude
that they gave a bunch of LSD to they
sat him in a table and they said put
this rifle together and he just like
looked at them like he had no [ __ ]
idea who he was or what was good what
and what I like is were there they're
interviewing the soldier and he's
standing there at pray dressed and
behind him as part of an obstacle course
and it's one with the telephone poles
that you have to climb it like a ladder
yeah and it kind of goes something a Jif
will slope and then goes down and they
you're gonna climb this okay now turn
around there's the obstacle he looks at
he just goes oh what's wrong man you
can't do it oh I know like what he was
seeing it was like yeah giant and it was
like all the way up into space and yeah
some people might want to know why the
hell would you ever want to consider LSD
as some kind of a non-lethal weapon or
or why would you want to weaponize that
it's for this very simple reason most
drugs have an overdose point all right
and if you're delivering a drug to a
certain area it's extremely difficult to
deliver in in a proper concentrations to
where it will be effective on the target
and not OD the person now usually
they're delivering it what some common
aerosol spray out of a helicopter or an
aircraft or maybe a mortar round or an
artillery shell that blows up in the air
well with LSD there isn't an overdose
point so the normal method of you know
of the normal method of delivery which
is like a crop-dusting plane you can use
that it doesn't matter if somebody gets
a really strong dose of it won't kill
him so that's what they were talking
about they wanted to know what the
effects of this would be if weaponized
you know what would it do on say a city
what would it do on a big division of
troops or a small unit like a like a
platoon what are the what are the
battlefield effects that's what they
wanted to know and and then they also
wanted to know how good was it for
interrogation
how good is it for wiping
memories away you know could you
persuade someone under the effects of
LSD to see things your way that type of
stuff because they did that as well when
some of the soldiers that were given LSD
then they would put them in an
interrogation room shine bright lights
in their face and you know ask them all
these different grouping questions and
stuff like that just to see what the
effect of it would be now like I said we
were talking about this yesterday I was
like I can totally understand why this
kind of research would need to be done
because I mean if quote-unquote enemy
governments or enemy armies or something
like that are gonna be using this on
your guys yes you have to know what it
is what it does notice other kind of
[ __ ] it was very attractive because yeah
chemically is safe yeah it's safe now
somebody might freak out and jump out a
window right which has happened but
chemically it's safe right like it won't
kill you the chemical itself yeah you
might hurt yourself because your
thinking was confused but they wanted to
know yeah they wanted to know could they
use this now project MKULTRA under that
name cuz as I said there was artichoke
before that there was Bluebird before
that it actually didn't become
officially MKULTRA until about April of
1953 it's interesting because it kind of
got a lot of funding because a few
months after it started there was an
incident that during the Korean War
where several American servicemen were
captured by the Koreans and they
admitted or they confessed that they had
dropped biological weapons on Korea
which you know so what ended up
happening there was that the government
started to I mean when they got the
American servicemen back they actually
they put them through their own
interrogation they you know put them out
in public and in public the servicemen
said you know we were brainwashed by the
Koreans they told us to say that we
didn't really drop biological weapons on
them and all this other kind of stuff so
I think MKULTRA was kind of I mean it
had its stated goals in place prior to
that yeah but I think that was kind of a
linchpin of why they wanted to go in
that particular
direction they wanted to see if people
could be brainwashed to say various
things if they could if you could you
know white people's memories away if you
could get them to espouse you know the
completely opposite views from what they
normally would now the question of
whether we actually did use biological
weapons on Korea is still controversial
they don't really know if all right now
I'd like to say something here yeah in
case there were people in the audience
that know don't know who I am I actually
would serve for one year on the DMZ in
Korea during the first Gulf War
I was stationed at a place called Camp
grieves Camp grieves is now like a like
a museum they predicted tourists to it
it's close it's right outside the DMZ
and when we were in the DMZ did the
mission it was a guard post Collier now
some of the old time vets probably know
exactly what I'm talking about it so I
used to see North Koreans you know and I
had friends that worked at JSA where
they hold the talks and I had friends
from from my same unit the first of 506
they also were at Liberty Bell which was
it was a company of the first the 506
that provided security for the places
where the talks were now we had seen
this North Korean claim for the the
biological weapons attacks they talk
about it but what they show in the
evidence that they show is very weak
that don't look like biological weapons
canisters that came out of the United
States program they just I mean anybody
could make what it is that they're
claiming is a bio dispersal canister
thing to me it looks like a drop tank
you know which is a fuel tank that you
strap underneath the bottom of a
propeller plane or a jet so what it
looks like and then it's kind of
segmented off but upon you know what I
found out later through some of the
studies we're talking about MKULTRA
there's a possibility that we may have
tested biological weapons on them there
would have been a motive for that in the
context of the Korean War the bombing
campaign that was going on we really had
no need for biological weapons because
we were really tearing the North Koreans
up I mean there there wasn't a building
taller than two storeys standing after
the bombing campaigns
but we were really afraid that China was
gonna get involved and MacArthur
mentioned possibly happened to get a
nuclear attack ready to use against
China
well that's cost MacArthur his job you
didn't wanna threaten nuclear war
against a big country like China but I
would think that the CIA may have wanted
to know whether or not a bio attack
against China would be effective because
it would be deniable so a good test
ground would have been North Korea and
what you do is you just send a couple
planes down there to drop some of these
canisters and then try to get an idea of
how many people actually died from that
amount of canister you know from say
like ten canisters how many people
actually died how much in pounds of
material did you need to deliver how do
you know use its vectors things like
mosquitoes you know how many of them you
have to deliver and how many people does
that kill how long does it take to
breathe enough of these vectors and
infect them to have an effective result
against China so you need the data just
to even compute whether or not an attack
is feasible right I think that that
maybe could happened yes and North Surry
saying that if it did happen then those
American servicemen had not necessarily
been brainwashed they might not have
been - right but the Koreans could have
said you know other guys did it we
capture them so you say who say it as we
know that you did and by looking at the
evidence yeah maybe they did test by a
weapon yeah and I'm saying not like a
large scale no based on my knowledge of
history the tactical situation in terms
of the terrain and the strategic
situation that happened in North Korea
chances are the test was negative in
other words the test probably didn't
have any right effective results it's
really hard to spread a disease the way
they tried to spread it back then
through banners and they did a lot of
experience
so the approach I don't know if you guys
know but they did they probably probably
ended up happening in realities they
drop some of these canisters they
weren't sure if people died or not right
okay and the North Koreans price said
yeah we think some people died in this
area because there's bombings and stuff
going on yeah yeah we know some people
already got sick and died what was that
from this attack we don't know so that's
probably this very inconclusive yeah
yeah I feel like that's probably what
happened but because of that incident
yeah you know the CIA got more involved
in you know trying to see can we
brainwash people can't we do this that
the others like I said it wasn't just
drugs it was other things it was it was
various torture techniques some of that
they did in Germany and using sensory
deprivation tanks hypnosis all this
other kind of stuff now the scary thing
about this is kind of at its height
MKULTRA comprised I mean they didn't
just do it at CIA spook headquarters
anything like that they actually farmed
it out to like a bunch of like
universities and psychiatric hospitals
and chasms and a lot of the and a lot of
the institutions that participated in
the research were actually given funding
through a CIA front companies so some of
them did not know that it was CIA [ __ ]
you got to tell them about the guy the
guy who jumped out the window yeah I
want to get into that after the break
because that's kind of really like a
really big story it's about time for a
break actually is it oh yeah okay so
we're at the halfway point right now so
when we get back I'm gonna get more into
the infamous case of Frank Olsen you and
I also want to talk about that village
in France which yeah maybe there's
something we'll talk about we'll talk
about that Hospital up in Canada
yeah that's pretty freaky yeah so yeah
well we'll get into that after the break
we'll be back in just a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back talking about MKULTRA
now when people talk about MKULTRA
mostly they're talking about the LSD
test yeah now at first the CIA
operatives who were working on this they
dosed themselves with LSD to see what
the effects would be and stuff like that
and although they wanted to know if you
could resist it like we trust this guy
Willis dose him right and then
interrogate him and yeah resistant you
know they also it should be noted then
this is where it kind of went off the
rails where they said well we don't need
to get anyone's consent because we want
to study how people react to LSD when
they don't know that they have been
given it yeah so they would set up like
they would set up say a brothel and they
would have these John's come in that
were just like random ass people they
would set up cameras behind one-way
mirrors they would have the prostitutes
give these people LSD and then they
would watch their reactions or film
their reactions
now they filmed them so they would have
blackmail material later on so the guy
can't be like hey you gave me LSD what
the [ __ ] man can there be like yeah well
at least have this if you having sex
with a prostitute and you probably don't
want anybody to know about that bro so
they would do that kind of [ __ ] they
also targeted vulnerable populations gay
men prisoners psychiatric patients
things like that with these various drug
studies with these various weird
hypnosis psychological breakdown type
things they did that kind of stuff and a
lot of times the people had no idea what
was going on what was going on the CIA
agents would also dose each other with
LSD without telling them yeah and this
is where we get to the case of Frank
Olsen and this is a very famous case now
it should be noted even though he is the
main death associated with MKULTRA there
was another guy named Harold blower he
actually died earlier in the year he
died
January 1953 and he was actually a
tennis player who had gone to a
psychiatric hospital to be treated for
depression after a divorce and he was
unwittingly subjected to various drugs
and things like that under the auspices
of the MKULTRA program and he ended up
dying so I just wanted to give him a
shout out because I feel like he kind of
just forgotten about I mean because
Frankel said it's kind of a lot let me
clarify it may clarify something though
some people might be wondering why the
hell would a CIA agent dose one of his
own kind without telling him and it
makes sense if you're a spook spooks
know stuff that they're not supposed to
tell yeah all right and you might want
to test another one of your guys by
dosing him up and trying to get him to
talk about what it is he knows if he
talks you know you can't trust him right
under the effects of LSD another thing
that it does is is it gets it keeps
these guys very wary of the effects of
drugs so they can recognize when they're
under the effects of drugs and fight it
so in other words they're building of a
drug resistance yeah that way an enemy
spook can't dose them and get anything
out of them because their friends have
already dosed him and tried to get [ __ ]
out of them they're dirty right they go
oh I know this yeah I'm tripping I know
that's basically what it is him back in
those days tripping was an edgy thing
you know people didn't know it but much
about tripping into it it's funny
because LSD really only seeped into the
counterculture because of this I guess
yeah because I mean it had been invented
in a lab LSD obviously and then it was
brought to the CIA is like hey maybe we
can use this as a truth serum or like to
confuse people or wipe their memories or
whatever tripping was new territory back
then and then later people like Ken
Kesey and stuff like that liked that you
know who had volunteered for LSD tests
he ended up liking the effects of it so
much like the mind-expanding side
effects of it that he actually kind of
brought it to the counterculture the
wider counterculture so actually the CIA
are probably responsible for that for
that whole LSD tripping hippie thing
okay so let's take it to the window man
tell us about window alright so Frank
Olson now if you have seen the Netflix
miniseries wormwood yes yeah well it's
actually very good it's it's they call
it a docudrama it's mostly a documentary
there's interviews with all the people
involved but there
also reenactment enactments I can't say
much about I can't I can't recommend
wormwood highly enough
it is very yes isn't it he plays Frank
Olson but then there's also interview
learn all about old school spooks yeah
and it is very I wanted to see because I
watched a bunch of different you know I
read a bunch of stuff about it and I
watched a bunch of different
documentaries about to see how accurate
were mode was to the facts that it seems
like pretty fairly accurate yeah so
Frank Olson was actually US Army captain
he was also a biochemist there you go
yeah now he had been working on
weaponizing various biological agents
particularly anthrax he was actually
working on aerosolizing yeah anthrax in
other words taking anthrax putting into
an aerosol form so you've been sprayed
out of a crop dusting military plane or
right or helicopter them now it should
be noted that one I can't remember what
year it was but actually on a
documentary about Frankel's and that I
saw his colleague who had worked on the
whole air anthrax thing with him said
you know we actually test it I mean
there's a lot of other tests too but one
of the most famous ones they actually
sprayed a biological agent that was
similar to anthrax on San Francisco yeah
it would spread to see it spread it was
I don't think anyone died a bunch of
people were hospitalized inert they just
wanted to see how how things spread
throughout an urban population yeah yeah
figuring out how effective your
biological weapons would be now to
clarification at the time that they were
doing this I don't think there was any
biological treaty with the Soviet Union
so this technically is not in violation
of any kind of treaty I don't think at
that time and if it was it wouldn't
matter those treaties don't worth the
paper they're written on well yeah well
I mean the the agreement that they made
after Nuremberg yeah was that they were
not allowed to experimental people
without their knowledge that's what they
say yeah yeah I'm just saying it did say
that so contravention of that when it
comes to the government and the spooks
those treaties aren't worth yeah they
don't pay whatever the hell they want
you can get around it yes so Frank Olson
as I said he got involved in the MKULTRA
program now there is a lot of
controversy about because at first
according to all his
friends and family he was a very
patriotic guy he was very who's into the
mission he was very into the mission he
thought it was a good thing to yeah this
is the biological version of the
Manhattan Project yeah so he was very
proud to be part of it
right but at some point he seems to have
started to develop moral quandaries
about the work that the CIA were
embarking on particularly how they're
experimenting on people who don't know
they're being experimented on that he
was watching a bunch of monkeys die yeah
killing monkeys a lot of monkeys is
bothering him yeah it was that was
starting to bother him and it was also
starting to bother him that they were
starting to experiment on yeah
vulnerable populations without telling
them what was going on so we're starting
to bother him and apparently he was a
prettty he wasn't afraid of speaking his
mind let's say so in 1953 he was invited
to a retreat at a place called Deep
Creek Lake while at this retreat
allegedly he was given LSD without
knowing about it it was put in his
Cointreau dosed he was dosed dosed in
the common parlance yes any club kid
should know yeah now nine days after
this get-together
he jumped fell or was pushed or thrown
or thrown yeah out of a 13th floor hotel
window in New York City yeah and then it
was made to look normal
yeah kind of brushed aside by the by the
media
yeah family in a way but well because at
first now Eric Olson has one of his sons
yeah she had three children Eric Olson
has kind of been behind this push to
find out what really happened to his
father at first I believe he was 9 years
old when his father died when Frank
Olson died and at first they said it was
an accident right which Eric Olson has
said you know he's like initially I like
immediately even though I was only nine
years old was like how you accidentally
fall out of a window are you
accidentally jumping out of a window in
the middle of the night yes seemed kind
of strange but then
they said well no it was a suicide right
which in a way sounded a little more
plausible because he had been having
doubts he had actually expressed to his
superiors that he wanted to quit yeah
they wanted to send him to a
psychiatrist
yeah they had actually sent him to to a
psychiatrist and he had actually told
his wife as well as his brother-in-law
that he's like I want to get out of this
I want to go be a dentist or something
like that I just can't really take it
anymore
apparently he had found out too much
information and he just couldn't handle
it so he wanted to get out so the fact
that he could have committed suicide was
maybe plausible yeah maybe he did based
on the programs and everything that we
saw and learned through this I think I
know what what what the deal was with
that and I pretty much agree with what
they show in Marin wormwood yeah but I
have a slightly different perspective of
it cuz I know the terrain I know where
it is they're talking about it you know
in Korea I don't know do you want to
tell him/her well what I was gonna say
what ended up happening because really
the [ __ ] about MKULTRA didn't come out
until 1975 yeah and actually because of
Watergate in 1973 the you know the stink
surrounding that the guy who was in
charge of the CIA at the time Helms he
actually destroyed most of the MKULTRA
documents because he was afraid yeah
we're all gonna get in [ __ ] trouble
right but he forgot a bunch of them so
the ones that came out afterwards
suggested that maybe there was more to
Frankel since death maybe there was more
going on with this MKULTRA [ __ ] that
they didn't want anybody to know so in
1975 the Olsen family were going to sue
the government now Gerald Ford was
president at the time and his joint
chiefs of staff were Dick Cheney and
Donald Rumsfeld yeah well let's get
those two guys those players have been
run forever yeah they are they now are
part of the military-industrial complex
and all the corporations now they said
to Gerald Ford and the memo of this has
since been Declassified they said look
we can't let the family sue because
there's a lot of really horrible
information in here that we don't want
going public yeah so why don't you just
invite them to the White House apologize
to them publicly you must watch and give
them a bunch of money and that's
essentially what happened
but as the years went on Eric Olsen
couldn't really let it go he's like you
know I think there's more going on than
meets the eye now in 1994 he had the
body of his father exhumed yeah and
there was another autopsy done
now what this autopsy seems to suggest
is that Frank Olson was hit on the head
probably knocked unconscious before he
was thrown out of the window yeah he was
killed he was executed so we're kind of
thinking I mean and Eric Olson is
definitely kind of thinking that the CIA
straight up murdered Frank Olson it was
an execution
it does generally seem like what seems
like happened based on the evidence is
that he was in there in this
manhattan-style project okay they're
making bio weapons and the idea you know
the main mission of these bio weapons is
you can use them against an enemy
clandestinely covertly and it's deniable
thing is is that bio weapons don't
really work that way they're really good
bioweapons that are effective they're
impossible to deny you know your enemy
did that you go this is anthrax you
haven't dropped this it's not really a
disease it's all spores yeah or okay
this is like a weaponized bubonic plague
so this isn't natural bubonic plague
yeah so it had to have been our enemies
that did this so we will retaliate with
nuclear weapons yeah the whole idea is
that you do it covertly you covertly SAP
your enemy away by getting him sick well
bioweapons don't work that way so I
think he became demoralized he they're
killing all these monkeys they're
testing it on people they're using them
in Korea and he knows that they're not
really effective weapons they're not
something that I think he kind of felt
like maybe it's all for nothing like all
this death and tragedy and it's not not
even an effective you're not gonna have
an effective deniable weapon right you
know so if it's not an effect it is not
deniable weapon just use the nuclear
weapons yeah the same thing yeah
basically might as well so I think he
got depressed and wanted to quit well he
did want to quit he had several people
that but you can't quit this is like
joining the because he knows
everything everything and he would talk
top security clearance right and he
would talk because he was upset about it
yeah I wanted to send him to a
psychiatrist and stuff who was actually
an allergist yeah so to cover their own
ass they suicided him yeah do him either
window and I think he knew about the
tests in North Korea yeah cuz that the
timing that certainly what I think that
was the decisive son Thanks and that's
what they had the journalist Seymour
Hersh ooze a quite a famous muckraking
journalist he actually had a source that
told him essentially he's like I think
the CIA executed this dude he's like I
can't prove it um he's like but I
definitely think that's what happened
now it should be noted that there was a
CIA like a manual yeah that came out the
first edition of it came out in 1953 I
believe and it says straight up in there
that the best way to assassinate
somebody with plausible deniability is
to drop them from a height of more than
75 feet onto a hard surface yeah and
then act like it's a suicide yeah and
then yeah and you pretend then you
become a witness yeah to say that you're
just a witness
right and then you do they can't
prosecute yes cute you it's like
straight out of the book but I think
what happened was is that he heard about
the test or knew about the test or took
part in the test in South in North Korea
even though I think that the results of
the test were probably inconclusive
right probably I don't think many people
died from it well like you said that
might have been part of him being like
disheartened about it yeah like you know
not only did we do this but is it even
who didn't work no it wasn't even I'm
sure some people died but probably not a
man he probably couldn't prove that that
many died from that right how you gonna
prove that they got bitten by the
mosquito that was in fact that's what I
mean that's why I always seem like that
kind of vector base like a bunch of you
know plague mosquitoes I'm like how the
hell which especially in korea koreas
all mountains and rice paddies there it
seemed like it would be hit or miss it
would you know wouldn't be reliable
yes spray it in an aerosol and you want
something that's like anthrax something
that hit it gets on the target and it
doesn't spread yeah that way it doesn't
come back and bite you
yeah anthrax is the best one but anthrax
isn't deniable well yeah because
you know somebody did that somebody made
that yeah now I want to talk a little
bit about two because this this was
another thing and I had actually never
really heard this made this connection
made but another documentary that I saw
about Frankel's and I think it came out
in 2002 they they did mention the
biological weapon and Korea thing and
maybe he knew about that they also
linked him they said now it's possible
that he might have had a link with a
very famous incident in 1951 and it
happened in a little village in France
yeah this is some good spook action yeah
this is what I'm talking about all the
lying and deception
yeah called pont-saint-esprit yeah as if
it's pretty small town in 1951
apparently a whole bunch of people in
the town went nuts all at once now it
ended up I think 300 people were
poisoned 50 of them had to be put in
psychiatric hospitals seven deaths one
of the men jumped out a window saying
that he was a dragonfly awesome and [ __ ]
like that now it [ __ ] yeah I guess it
was yeah now the official story for this
because they did eventually trace the
poison back to the town's bakery and
they said now everybody that was
poisoned had eaten bread from this
particular big guy or a guy so first
they thought it was Rio gap however yeah
the effects of the drug as described by
the witnesses a lot of people start to
think that this was some this was LSD or
some type of LSD drug and that this was
a spook operation yeah and that Frank
Olson might have known about this he
might not have been there he
demonstrably was in Europe like
according to his passport and stuff like
that around the time that that happened
because he went back and forth there
were some experiments in Germany going
on as well which actually he actually
did see some [ __ ] that went on in
Germany at Camp King yeah some
interrogation techniques and stuff like
that and when he came back he said I
mean he basically was like he saw some
[ __ ] I think that was kind of the
beginning at the end like where he
want to do this anymore he's like I saw
people die I saw like the all the
horrible things they were doing to these
people that were supposedly communist
sympathizers on you know double agents
that kind of thing
and he's like just the [ __ ] they did to
these people it was just horrible but
getting back to the to the French bakery
yeah that's a perfect place for a spook
do so you go in there you sneak it
through the back of the bakery or you
hire somebody to drop something into the
dough and that's it and everybody gets
dosed in a town you get to not everybody
but a lot everybody they eat the bread
yeah everybody gets a bread gets dosed
in the town and you can study the
effects what's it like to spray a bunch
of arrow aerosolized LSD on a town what
does it do you know can do the people do
nothing or do they how many of them die
how many of them hurt themselves how
many of them just you know no effect so
that's probably what they wanted to know
and of course Riya got and the bakery is
the cover story or wasn't us yeah must
have gives just Riya got you know
because that doesn't mean moldy bread
yeah it's happened I mean that doesn't
say that that was intensely strong and I
don't think that was some kind of a you
know that sounds like a synthetic you
know it definitely day now they they
were somehow able determined that the
Baker himself was not responsible
because at first they were like oh the
Baker poisoned everybody's for shits and
giggles or something like that but they
were somehow it was it wasn't him so
there is some speculation that that
might have been a CIA operation because
as I said they actually did do similar
things in the United States also there
were there are an alarming alarming
amount of [ __ ] that likes obscure and
you know they obscure and they subvert
yeah they could get you to believe
things that aren't true right yeah
now I also want to talk a little bit
before the end of the show I want to
talk a little bit about dr. Cameron in
Canada and a little bit of his research
now apparently he was doing all this
kind of [ __ ] with memory-wiping and
stuff like that
under the auspices of the CIA but CIA
memos that have been disc lassic
Declassified suggests that he didn't
know that he was working for the CIA but
his thing was he did something called
psychic driving he also worked on
something called deep patterning which
he actually it sounds pretty sinister I
can see how you would want
to explore this Avenue he was actually
working on treating schizophrenic and he
thought that the best way to do that was
to essentially erase the illness or
erase their personalities and then start
over it so total mind wipe and then you
reboot that person like they were an
infant yeah that's so yeah it's a little
extreme yeah and how they do it is bad
now there is there was one woman who has
been interviewed on several
documentaries now evidently she went to
see him to be treated for postpartum
depression it's very common very simple
saying and evidently they thought she
would make a good subject for this
research and they pretty much erased her
personality I mean it took a long time
they used various drugs they use as I
said sensory deprivation might have been
electroshock therapy hang on to this
using that also what that means is they
take a person they strap them down onto
a bed in a padded cell with dark no
sound no light can come in from the
outside they probably hook you up with
IV feeding and catheters and stuff like
that and then they leave you in there
for months yeah with just like a
recording of a voice repeating the same
thing over and over and over again give
you a bunch of LSD and it just fries
your brain just yeah every bit of you
just is gone
yeah so you have like a bout of amnesia
when you come out of there you can't
talk you can't walk all your skills are
God she's forgotten everyone you're a
damn infant yeah pretty much
I've heard that some people will one
time one book I read said that they
could do that this person like almost up
to a year in that little cell thanks dad
can you imagine it breaks you and that
breaks you again and then you go beyond
broken to where your spirit your mind
just vanish yeah then they bring you out
of there like a newborn oh can you I
can't imagine that oh yes she had to I
mean she seems normal now but she said
it took her about 20 years to get back
to normal she had to be retaught had a
talk [ __ ] to be retaught everything
because she remembered before the
procedure I don't think she could
actually I think it does basically kill
you
basically kills your mind yes so she had
to be retaught every hand sander
evidently they did that to a lot of
people yes I'm terrified they were doing
that up in Canada yeah they were weird
and the dude that was doing it was doing
it for the CIA yeah but but apparently
he didn't know he was doing it for the
CIA yeah he got he ended up getting like
I think the CIA gave him six hundred
thousand dollars in today's money to do
that research but without saying oh hey
it's for the CIA
just do what you're doing just like wipe
out some people's memories already like
half a million bucks right that's scary
but yeah so that went on too that would
be a cleaner and easier way of getting
rid of one of your ages you know I mean
if he knew something you thought he's
gonna talk you know you know tell the
public about our biological tests let's
not kill him this is a racist mice it's
mine Yeah right yeah and the thing is
okay so evidently after the whole thing
blew up in 1975 and everybody then
everybody knew about MKULTRA evidently
the CIA says they didn't do that anymore
they said and the guy that ran the
program doctor said the Sidney Gottlieb
he has basically come out and said we
didn't really find any useful
information out of it it was kind of a
waste of time nuts I don't know if he
said that but he said that kind of
saying it's like it wasn't really a
really effective program and that they
stopped it but some people that are kind
of experts in CIA kind of [ __ ] was like
now they probably didn't stop doing that
they just calling it something else but
the thing is that we kind of talked
about this yesterday brainwashing in the
sense of erasing someone's personality
and replacing it with you know something
you want yeah there's a lot of
controversy over how possible that
actually is I'm not saying that you
can't just totally erase someone's mind
by just [ __ ] them up like you said
putting them in sensory deprivation
putting them on tons of drugs and stuff
yeah you can totally [ __ ] up a person to
make them like a baby and stuff like
that but will they eventually come back
even if they need treatment to come back
according to that won't look for that
one woman no yeah she couldn't remember
that they even did it to her she hadn't
remember anything be high you know
anything before it yeah so it could be
that those memories you were just erased
and who knows what it is that those tape
recordings that you know that is playing
over and over again yeah I be that you
know you are nothing you are nothing
you are nothing or something like that I
think kind of the problem with this type
of research and I'm not saying that it's
not effective on some type of people
yeah
or some types of people is that it seems
like it would be really I do synchronic
because every individual is different um
you don't know how effective it's gonna
be on one person as opposed to another
person some people might be stronger
well it might be assuming that some
people break early yes some people break
later but I'm assuming that eventually
they all break oh I'm the only
difference is is that some people can be
in there for a month and other people
might take a year yeah probably a thing
like brainwashing it's kind of like
biological warfare it just seems like
it's not predictable enough to be super
effect well here's another thing I could
be wrong about that here's another thing
what if you want to hide the truth
what's more effective taking a guy
wiping his mind out and then putting him
somewhere alright where people recognize
him maybe and go Weymouth why are you so
different
what's more effective that or just
killing the [ __ ] that's what I
mean I would think just kill him just
kill him so I think that's why you don't
censor meat it's like why go to all the
trouble just wanted to know yeah cuz
they're spooks what's just right yeah
it's they do trail maybe there was maybe
there was a situation where they wanted
to know because there were certain
individual people they didn't want dead
but they did whatever any want right so
it seems like a lot of trouble to go
through to go through months and months
or years of like erasing this person's
memory or reprogramming they're not over
when you when you could just throw them
out a window like oh yeah and then you
don't have to hide it he jumped yeah he
could just be like a song it was an
accident or a suicide just sounds like
it would be so much easier yes so that's
why they do that mostly as I said on
wormwood the Netflix show when they were
talking to Seymour Hearst the
journalists at the end even though he
wouldn't say anything definitive on
camera cuz he's like I'm afraid I'm
gonna get in trouble I don't want my
source to get in trouble he said all I'm
gonna say is that the CIA have a
procedure yeah for dealing with he's
like basically saying straight up that
they do execute people in that fashion
well all you gotta do is just look at
recent history you know a lot of Peter
and a lot of people have jumped a lot of
people have yea wrecked their cars in
the averman a lot of people have
committed suicide
in the government and people connected
to people in the government it's fishy
so yeah I mean I'm not saying that every
single one of them is like an execution
or assassination but if there's like a
bunch of them I don't feel like yeah yes
particularly in the case of Frank Olson
who was he had top security clearance he
knew all the [ __ ] about biological
warfare you possibly knew about that
village of France he knew about all the
horrible [ __ ] there's no way Germany he
could always tell who was rubbed out by
what they knew and the timing yeah the
timing and the information that they had
yeah because oh this guy just happened
to be opening a lawsuit on this guy here
and just right before the indictment
happened he died he can't suicide
imagine that yeah and it should be noted
like I said Frank Olson a week before he
died had actually gone to his superiors
so you know I think I'm gonna quit of
course so in there like yeah they
thought he was gonna blab because he was
ever depressed everybody knew he'd been
depressed for a while like his wife said
his family said his his colleague said
it they didn't want him to blow the OP
and they knew that he and more than one
of them said he quote/unquote talked too
much yeah and he had a family so you
couldn't Mindwipe him yeah so you know
he's sending back to his family like
what happened to you yeah you're weird
but yeah yeah they made it so he jumped
and like I said it's right there in the
CIA assassination manual that's the best
way to assassinate somebody yeah yeah so
poor guy but yeah definitely check out
wormwood check out like Frankel's that
are Eric Olson has a big website where
he's trying to you know kind of get to
the bottom of what happened to his dad
and all this other stuff there's tons
and tons of documentaries on this kind
of we kind of just scratched the surface
and like I said it was kind of
ramshackle cuz they were kind of all
over but there was a bunch of interest
yeah it's this huge huge subject like I
said more than a hundred and fifty
different sub projects that were working
on all kinds of different things so you
know I would encourage you if you're
interested in it this is just kind of a
broad yeah rambling introduction like we
usually do so he definitely requests you
know so we have to you know yeah and
like I said more than one person
requested this is actually a fascinating
topic the only
that I hadn't done it before now is cuz
I felt like it was daunting it's really
very large but you know I think we did
okay yeah so that'll do is a good
overview yeah it's a good overview show
yeah so that'll do it for this episode
hope you enjoyed it if you liked the
show please remember to Like share
subscribe on all your social media and
if you would like to support the show
you can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock or you can
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast at wordpress calm and there's a
link in the sidebar to a PayPal account
if you'd like to give a one-time
donation also remember to check out our
latest movie review which was the 1977
sci-fi horror film demon seed based on a
book by Dean Koontz and if you would
like some swag with our beautiful
designs on it we have t-shirts and also
a tote bag at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock and that will do it for episode
81 we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]